buen día nuevamente usualmente estamos
en directo desde el parlamento peruano
acaba de culminar la juramentación de
manuel de merino el con una mano en la
biblia prometió trabajar por beneficio
de los peruanos
merino ha señalado que esta situación se
debe vivir como interesa moral porque es
un momento muy difícil para el país y
que los ciudadanos deben de actuar
respetando la democracia merino ha
señalado que una de sus principales
acciones va a ser reforzar la salud para
atender eficientemente la pandemia del
gobi 19 y en ese sentido ha dicho que va
a corregir errores del pasado otro
aspecto de su discurso ha sido referente
a la reactivación económica el nuevo
presidente de los peruanos ha anunciado
que va a impulsar la economía y generar
nuevos puestos de trabajo en lo que se
refiere a lo que es la integración de la
ciudadanía el apellido la unidad de los
peruanos y ha dicho que va a hacer
respetar
democrático justamente esta ceremonia de
transición de este gobierno de
transición se demoró porque precisamente
manuel merino se reunió con altos mandos
militares ellos expresaron su
reconocimiento como presidente y le
juraron lealtad como jefe supremo de las
fuerzas armadas del perú esta
inauguración presidencial en realidad es
inusual no hay la presencia de
mandatarios de otros países como ha sido
característica solamente han llegado a
algunos representantes de
miembros diplomáticos acreditados en
esta nación pero lo que sí hay es
protesta ciudadana que se ejerce en
diversos lugares del perú justamente
enigma en la conocida plaza salmantina
hay alrededor de 400 manifestantes que
están tratando de ingresar al parlamento
peruano para hacer expresar su voz de
protesta